et puis un autre retour avant de
refermer cette édition celui de charles
aznavour à partir de ce soir et pour un
mois au palais des congrès à paris à 70
ans charles aznavour marche sur les
traces de charles trenet avec un succès
pratiquement assuré louis carzou et
alain du ballon rencontre est long à
bout s'appuyer sur 50 ans de carrière
avoir plus de 400 chansons dans sa
besace il n'y a rien à faire une veille
de première à paris
francs à lagord rage en et trois
bouteilles en bas ça vous en faites pas
on n'en trouve pas vous avez ensuite
pharmacie vous il vous en reste une
seule h 30-12 du cir ou qui prendrait
presque le but d'un vent de jeunesse car
dès qu'il s'agit de remonter sur les
planches
charles aznavour a l'âge de ses
parterres celui où on a la passion de
partager des mets où l'on à longvic tout
simplement de chanter
son autonomie zares
observer
bobby
un chanteur on est un chanteur bon c'est
très bien bravo j'adore les chanteurs
long surtout que souvent ils chantent
des chansons à moi dont je les adores en
plus mais moins je me suis jamais
considéré comme un chanteur et je pense
que si je n'avais pas écrit j'aurais pas
chanter genre était uniquement comme il
vient donc d toujours d'abord considéré
comme un auteur considéré par moi même
comme un auteur par les autres gens
sérieux
l'acteur le chanteur l'auteur au fond
qu'importe ce que dit le haut de la
fiche la capitale a rendez vous avec
charles aznavour et tous et toutes
répondent présents
je reviendrai
je referais pas
alors
m